what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today to watch
the trailer for a movie that i thought
this trailer was coming out at like six
in the morning but it came out in the
evening in l.a halloween ends still
positive with the vid diesel
unfortunately tested positive a few days
after johnny boy did but hopefully we're
both clear by the time comic con rolls
around because i'm sure there's going to
be a lot of goodies but right now we got
to rock this trailer i really enjoyed
the third first halloween movie really
enjoyed halloween kills as well so i'm
very excited for this wanted to mention
a couple things shout out reaction to
the movie sinister first time watching
so i'm gonna try to get that up tomorrow
or thursday and in case you missed our
major announcement uh we recently
partnered up with heavy spoilers and
screen crush or a one-stop nerd shop for
all of our merch got a whole bunch of
great gear to represent yourself as a
citizen of the reject nation but also
got a bunch of stranger things inspired
here as well the main show i want to
tell you about is a limited run inspired
by one from stranger things and one from
squid game and we put one and one
together you can go to shop0edition.com
and explore around you know see if
there's anything that you like anything
you guys get is a great way to support
the channel meantime leave a like that'd
be awesome and let's see the trailer for
the
final final final showdown
with the it won't be though there's
always more
[Music]
what we got
chillin
[Music]
let's go
ouch
flashbacks
come and get me [ __ ] yeah
come on
i fear that
it's such like a primal fear if anyone
whoever deals a garbage disposal
i think that's a reference to one of the
halloween movies isn't it is that
h2o
let me know if i'm right about that
every time i actually use a garbage
disposal i think his final destination
was the first movie i ever saw that
really tempted with that and other
movies have done it too but whenever i
put my hand in a garbage disposal i'm
like oh my god please don't turn on i'm
really enjoying the showdown moment that
they're teasing us with i'm assuming
it's from the finale of the film or it
could be like one of two or three fights
between them you know like it's taking
place a few years after halloween kills
i could imagine a scenario where you
know someone feels inspired to become
michael myers or dress up like him and
then i'm going to attack lori and have
some true crime serial killer wish
fulfillment going on but i mean this
looks like this is the real michael
myers in this scene but the first
installment from this trilogy
while i like loved that finale i really
did it was a lot of machinations and
contraptions a lot of strategy this is
just bringing us to a brutal raw
visceral fight bare knuckle house
brawling nunia which feels like apt for
this climactic showdown the boogeyman
the ferocious unstoppable force and the
resilience of lori strode going
toe-to-toe and like this physically
brute match and even the ending shot of
lori stabbing michael's hand reflecting
the iconic imagery of michael meyer
stabbing kind of weaves in thematically
what this trilogy has been doing of
lori's traumatic obsession in some ways
evolving her into what she obsesses
about i'm not saying she's going to
become a serial killer or anything like
that but but i don't think you know what
i'm getting at you you've seen the other
two movies but i have faith in this
movie i like the halloween 2018 2018 if
i'm correct i like that one more than uh
halloween kills and they have had two
movies planned and originally it was
gonna be shot back to back but they
actually wanted to wait and see how
kills was received first so they can
acclimate and readjust especially
because while there was like still a lot
of halloweenisms in that film they did
try doing different things in terms of
audience reception some of it didn't
land so well some of it did evil dies
tonight so i do wonder how much social
commentary they're gonna try to push in
here because halloween kills definitely
try doing more social commentary than i
think the first halloween movie i think
i think that halloween movie definitely
was doing it but it was a little bit
more overt in halloween kills at least
in my perception but i think this
particular trilogy works best when the
themes really shine through the
characters emotional experiences and
what they're going through so when you
keep it like just character focused
specifically on lori strode obviously
who was a miss presence for a lot of
halloween kills but i feel like
especially with the death of judy greer
that's really setting the stage for what
this film is gonna offer like i think
this is a great first trailer it doesn't
give you a lot which is ideally the way
you want it to go when it comes to your
horror suspenseful movie it feels like
halloween opening on halloween with its
pov voyeuristic stalking shot misleads
you into thinking like oh is someone
tied up there or is michael just about
to kill another person then you're
walking in again to lori's trap which is
again establishing like
this is what this trilogy does i did
read up that this movie's gonna be
taking place i believe four years after
the last movie and that it would
incorporate elements of the pandemic
into the story i don't really quite know
how much again social commentary but
what i'm most interested in seeing and i
hope they really do justice to this is
that we're supposed to be seeing how the
town of haddonfield who was already just
vastly disturbed and and traumatized for
decades after a few killings in 1978 i
can only imagine how much worse it is
for them after the events from four
years before so i'm interested to see
how they're gonna handle the coping of
the community and how that's all gonna
unfold yeah i know i wanna see a bunch
of cool kills and thrills too but i
wanna see some cool thematic [ __ ] happen
as well what is the actual plot synopsis
of this movie hold on let me find it
four years after the events of halloween
kills lori is living with her
granddaughter allison and is finishing
writing her memoir michael myers hasn't
been seen since lori after allowing the
spectre michael to determine and drive
her reality for decades has decided to
liberate herself from fear and rage and
embrace life but that shape just kicks
goddamn door but when a young man corey
cunningham is accused of killing a boy
oh i actually didn't read this man is
accused of killing a boy he was
babysitting and ignites a cascade of
violence and terror that will force
laurie to finally confront the evil she
can't control once and for all evil dies
tonight well that's interesting so i do
wonder if the angle of this corey
cunningham character is someone who
actually did kill this child or is being
framed by michael myers who's like i'm
referring to this guy
i'm not sure but i think there is some
interest like i was talking about
earlier uh in this discussion that
perhaps there might be some type of
influence some psychotic
sick influence left behind and then this
kid is inspired by it or some [ __ ] and
then michael comes back and michael's
like i'm gonna adopt you corey you're
mine so yeah with halloween kills
wanting to even more social commentary
and i know they want to carry that
through here so from the sounds of
things with michael haven't been gone
for several years that again they'll be
continuing that theme of dealing with
trauma the struggles of letting go and
challenges to move forward oh man this
franchise is the soviet laureate
she's such a sarah connor character in
the 2018 film and in this film they're
setting her up i'm like i decided to let
go and i'm going to enjoy my life and be
here be at one and then bam freaking
just when i think come out they pull me
back in and yeah you know with the way
holloman kills ended with the the death
of uh judy cruz oh my god i'm looking
around judy gru's kid karen do you
wonder if we're gonna kind of get some
type of cathartic vengeance tail woven
here you know where
like lori and allison are coming
together they gotta avenge the bomb but
either way uh i thought this was a great
first trailer i'm excited for this movie
what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell you can check us out at
shopzeroaddition.com support the channel
and yeah we will catch you all soon